[Musique]
donc atteint
impossible pour damien d'oublier cette
journée du 4 mars 2012 les ordonnances
médicales et les radiographies qu'ils
conservent chez lui sont là pour
rappeler comment sa vie a basculé en
quelques secondes ce matin-là le dépôt
d'armes du pilat en plein coeur de
brazzaville explose
un bruit sourd et anti dans la capitale
congolaise qui servaient sous une pluie
de débris le tympan droit de dames hier
est touché aujourd'hui il n'entend plus
que l'oreille gauche pendu à une salle
même quand on parle des obligés parfois
je me penche vers la gauche parce que
c'est là bas que je vais écouter
l'oreille droite est supprimé malgré la
forte on me wade vous n'allez pas voir
que j'ai l'impact or il s'agit du tampon
qui a été perforé c'est un handicap qui
paie le tampon d'amis a été ton chemin
pour rendre visite à un manque lorsque
l'explosion a retenti
instinctivement il se met à courir avant
de se coucher à même le sol dans cette
ruelle cet endroit là pour moi c'est un
mauvais souvenir j'avais rendre le voir
mme pilar lorsque je me mets à sortir on
a entendu deux coups non pour s'abriter
un peu plus proche j'avais choisi la
réponse que parce que et à ma maman que
j'ai c'est bien qu'elle habitait là
explosion souffle tout sur son passage
treize quartiers dont deux de 9
arrondissement de brazzaville sont
touchés dix sept mille familles se
retrouvent à la rue du jour au lendemain
aujourd'hui encore beaucoup vivent dans
des maisons de fortune c'est le cadet
paul qui vit dans ce hangar avec son
épouse et ses cinq enfants
transformation des enfants donc enlevé
là comme ça on ne peut rien parce que on
peut par ménage et on vous allez aménagé
comme entrant type le 7 août un calvaire
au lendemain de l'explosion le
gouvernement congolais avait promis des
réponses truire les maisons des
sinistrés mais cette promesse n'a jamais
été ténue et l'état n'a proposé aucune
solution pour reloger les victimes
aujourd'hui paul dîner plus rien
attendre des autorités
voilà plus de plier à la faire on va
payer quoi que l'état congolais fasse ce
qu'il veut
puisque la terre et les cieux leur
appartient qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils
veulent il ya même nos parents les vieux
sont morts ils ont longtemps attendu ça
ne vient pas ils sont décédés nous
sommes restés même bientôt là nous
allons aussi parce que certains
sinistrés n'ont pas pour autant renoncé
à faire valoir leurs droits et ont
engagé un bras de fer avec le
gouvernement
environ 200 familles occupent de façon
irrégulière ces maisons appartenant à
l'état elles ont été plusieurs fois
chassés mais ont finalement obtenu
l'autorisation d'y rester c'est le cas
de steve qui habitent ici avec sa femme
et ses quatre enfants depuis 2014 une
situation précaire car il n'a signé
aucun bail nous avons été expulsés
est il de masse de manifestations
sociales
est humaine ras-le-bol vis-à-vis de
l'état ce que nous attendons
gouvernement ce qu'elle vous nous venons
prenne ses responsabilités qu'ils nous
donnent tout leur temps pour que nous
puissions régler la radio je continue à
tomber nos maisons ont négocié avec le
gouvernement mais victimes du 4 mars
2012 en créer un collectif brunehault
s'était en est le président au départ le
gouvernement avait pensé pouvoir
reconstruire les maisons des sinistrés
mais ils se sont rendu compte que
c'était cher trop cher et donc le
gouvernement a finalement décidé de ne
plus aller dans ce sens que l'argent
soit donnée aux ayants droit aux
sinistrés pour que eux mêmes ils
reconstruisent leur maison sous la
pression des victimes le gouvernement a
finalement débloqué en décembre dernier
un milliard de francs cfa soit un
million cinq cent mille euros il a aussi
promis six milliards de francs cfa
supplémentaires avant le 4 mars 2022 une
somme qui n'a toujours pas été révélé
aux victimes le fait de personnes
reconnaître lundi et pour votre gouverne
nous avons discuté avec le cône ministre
on devait régler cette dette mais en
trois phases ils ont donné leur bonne
volonté en libérant dans le milieu ne
pousse ceux qui s'affichent la csu
millions que nous entendons au lendemain
de la catastrophe le gouvernement avait
évalué le coût des reconstructions
hauteur de 233 milliards de francs cfa
soit 355 millions d'euros sollicité ni
le premier ministre ni le porte parole
du gouvernement n'ont donné suite à nos
demandes d'interview